la page mode maintenant début des
défilés aujourd'hui des collections
printemps-été 89 des grands couturiers
ce soir christian lacroix et 30
reportage de yoga grégoire et didier da
légère fluide enveloppé de mousseline
fin maharaja ou romantique à l'anglais
c'est la femme fan transparence coquine
ligne près du corps longueur au genou à
la cheville quelquefois au mollet
suivant l'humeur
d'ailleurs tricolore pour bicentenaire
tu es glamour pour le soir-même matière
pour bell du soir une collection
féminine est radieuse ch et aux rentes
ligne trapèze robes au genou pantalons
larges jaune citron et fuchsia les
couleurs fétiches de christian lacroix
nostalgie des anciennes colonies
influence de lorient qui nous fait rêver
tout comme ses robes
délicates broderies pour ce bon show en
organza une collection romantique et
exotique tout à la fois qui le temps
d'un défilé nous fait voyager dans les
pays lointains
voilà